soon the msg sphere behind the venetian
is taking shape looking more
spherical right now it's on track to
become the largest
spherical structure in the world once
it's finished in 2023
this afternoon we got a closer look at
the construction progress hector mejia
live with the details hector looks
pretty cool out there right now
it looks really cool and crews are
working right now in the heat what you
see on the bottom portion the gray
colored paneling that's actually
insulated metal paneling on the outside
it's not the led screen
that will cover the entire sphere yet
and it's so impressive
when you stand right underneath it you
really have to tilt your head
all the way up just to see the top part
of the sphere
and we took a 90 minute nearly 90 minute
walking tour inside earlier this morning
to take a close look
of the future msg sphere at the venetian
it stands if you're wondering 366 feet
tall
and it's more than 500 feet wide and
just recently crews have completed
building
the domed roof frame about 6 million
pounds worth of steel
so all of that is what allows the
project to have an interior bowl without
columns in it
and once it's all done in 2023 it will
have a maximum capacity of 20 thousand
people
all facing the front stage there's not
going to be a bad seat in the house
other venues of this size definitely
don't offer that
off with it we will have a fully uh
immersive led screen that comes up and
around
and comes down and behind it will be one
of the largest led screens in the world
it is the size of approximately three
football fields
so the tower you see in the middle of
the screen there is part of the
construction process it will
be removed once the project is finished
this will be a venue for more than just
concerts imagine watching
boxing esports and other major events
and back out here once it's done
the sphere you see right now will once
it's done it'll be
actually 30 percent taller than what you
see now
so they still have a bit more to go and
if you're wondering
what or who will be the opening act we
asked but it's
too early to tell reporting live hector
mejia 8 news now